[Musique]
pour noter le spectateur il est 20h33
est-ce que vous pouvez résumer ce qui se
passe exactement là-bas Gilles Verdez
qui sort tout droit qui sort du bien
juste de sortir du Ramadan voilà
exactement puisqu'il vient de manger
pour la merci et vous avez des messages
Bruno c'est des gens qui vous voient la
télé
c'est super à la télé c'est dans les
Deux Sèvres c'est un endroit où il doit
y avoir des retenues d'eau gigantesques
on parle de 6 millions de mètres cubes
qui vont permettre d'irriguer 450
agriculteurs ces agriculteurs ils ont
passé un pacte avec l'État qui paye 76
millions d'euros et beaucoup de gens
tous les opposants là manifestaient en
critiquant le fait que on cède à ces
agriculteurs comme ça et qu'on retienne
l'eau pour irriguer leur culture donc il
y a deux clans face à face et là les
manifestants n'avaient pas le droit
d'être présent à Sainte Soline c'était
interdit et ce sont adjoint à eux 1000
irréductibles casseurs
membres de ultra de l'extrême gauche qui
ont voulu attaquer les forces de l'ordre
et ça a dégénéré d'une manière
incroyable
ultra violente voilà oui Bruno vous
confirmez oui oui absolument c'est
effectivement c'est ces groupuscules
d'extrait de gauche
je rigole c'est pas marrant d'ailleurs
parce que non
ces groupuscules les extraits beau gosse
effectivement à cause de gros problèmes
aux forces de l'ordre on le sait depuis
pas mal de temps et il faut savoir que
parmi ces 6000 manifestants qui avaient
enfin 5000 vraies manifestants on peut
dire pacifique qui venait pour
revendiquer les choses et pourquoi pas
encore que la terre était interdite donc
encore une fois l'État a été tolérant
mais en même temps de voir assurer la
sécurité parce que c'est c'est la base
même la constitution des silics comme ça
il y a une manif il y a des services de
police qui sont présents c'est comme ça
ça ne changera jamais bon là vous l'avez
vu Cyril à l'instant comment les les
forces de l'ordre se sont fait canard
bon je dis pas que ce sont des
délinquants ce sont des assassins en
devenir c'est des assassins franchement
parce que ces gens-là viennent un peu de
toute l'Europe c'est des extrémistes
c'est ultra les renseignements
territoriaux les connaissent pour
certains mais ces gens-là aucune c'est
intéressant cette cette caméra je peux
vous assurer que les gendarmes et j'en
ai eu au téléphone je peux vous assurer
que les gendarmes ont eu très très peur
aussi et pourtant ce sont des gens des
gaillards qui ont peur de rien donc ces
gens-là et bien à un moment donné il
faut je dirais pas les neutraliser parce
que ça irait loin mais il faut trouver
un moyen de pouvoir les les interpeller
et que cela c'est parce que encore une
fois ça fait du taux à la manifestation
de façon générale qui plus est
lorsqu'elle n'est pas autorisée mais en
plus de façon générale au projet des
retraites etc on voit aussi ces ultra
dans les retraites à Paris oui mais à
quel moment on peut trouver des
cocktails Molotov des mortiers des
bidons d'essence des haches des
machettes des boules de pétanque et des
dizaines de couteaux donc ils sont juste
là pour casser du flic en fait pour
absorber ce faut comprendre c'est que il
y a un filtre qui a été fait plus ou
moins parce que la surface qui est
couverte par les gendarmes est énorme on
l'a vu filtrer tout ça c'est quasiment
impossible et à un moment donné
effectivement on a retrouvé 60 boules de
pétanque des couteaux des haches on
retrouve enfin tous les moyens qui sont
possibles qu'utilisent même les
guerriers roses dans certains pays
pourquoi ils viennent à nous en fait ils
viennent de toute l'Europe pourquoi on
peut pas les stopper pourquoi on arrive
c'est compliqué qui sont fichiers qui
sont connus il y en a peut-être deux ça
de radicaliser qu'on connaît très bien
il y en a plus de 2000 entre 2000 et
3000 euros qui sont effectivement
des services plus ou moins connus et
services police et qu'on retrouve
systématiquement toutes les opérations
la manifestation elle était interdite
mais finalement tolérée vu la flux de
monde quand il y avait ces filtres là et
notamment on parle de 2009 on les
repères cela on les connaît mettre un
garde à vue systématiquement parce que
c'est pas possible qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
commis rien de vue donc un moment donné
tout ça ça passe est sur une encore une
fois sur une périphérique comme il y a
là pour sécuriser c'est quasiment
impossible la seule chose qui avait les
forces de l'ordre d'affaires donc les
gendarmes en l'occurrence là c'est
pouvoir se prépositionner autour de
l'installation et d'empêcher les
d'empêcher des manifestants les ultras
violents surtout pas les manifestants
de tous les autres ils gâche tout mais
si on en autorisé quand même c'est que
on aurait dû parce qu'il y avait des
politiques et des présidents et
tondeliers etc des élus de la République
était présent c'est un scandale de voir
ces gens-là présent alors que si vous
avez été un peu intelligent mais on en
doute c'est d'organiser tout simplement
une manifestation de la déclarer que ces
politiques aillent avec les les
mouvances écologiques préparer la
manifestation en orbe et je pense qu'on
aurait pu éviter ça parce que il y
aurait eu comme on l'a vu dans les
dernières manifestations à Paris
ailleurs les services d'ordre qu'on voit
et que vous allez voir demain en action
qui vont pouvoir protéger le cortège
éviter le pire faut savoir que les
dernières manifestations que nous avons
eu là ce sont relativement bien passés
c'est-à-dire que les services d'ordre
des syndicats étaient présents en nombre
les policiers les CRS et on fait leur
rôle de sécurisation de la manifestation
et on avait les bras les fameuses braves
dont on parle on va parler sûrement
alors était là pour intervenir sur les
sur les colonnes avec nous demain ouais
voilà je vous dis on va écouter le
témoignage assez chaud d'un reporter qui
était présent sur place on l'appellera
Thibault parce qu'il a peur des
représailles d'abord écouter le contexte
dans lequel il s'est retrouvé entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
écoutez
l'ambiance elle était plutôt festive il
y avait de la musique
voilà tout simplement enchaîner
directement avec les premières tensions
enfin agir sur ça voilà
qui ont commencé à s'approcher d'un
cortège et ils ont utilisé du gaz
lacrymogène de transformation il y avait
des il y avait des personnes
il était Gaza en premier et après
c'était vraiment tout le monde et
d'ailleurs il y a une vidéo qui tourne
où il tire à la va-vite le
coin d'été en mode Mad Max alors ensuite
entre les policiers et les manifestants
les affrontements deviennent vite très
tendus sachez que c'est un document
exclusif de TPMP très tendu et ils
assistent à des scènes très très
choquantes
policiers ont tenté deux charges de bons
offensifs et ils ont été repoussés par
les manifestants ensuite il y a eu un
corps un corps entre
5 signes et 5 6 man
ifestes aux abords de la bassine
vraiment juste devant les barrières
après j'ai vu des gens prendre des
grenades à distance dans les jambes et
qui
emboîtant et qui étaient accompagné par
des manifestants qui les accompagné dans
une série zone alors en tant que
reporter inévidemment pas protégé ni
armée contre ce qui se passe et entre ni
les manifestants ni les forces de coûts
c'est le choc et la peur lui qui
pourtant a couvert beaucoup de
manifestations apparemment il avait
jamais connu ça regardez écoutez
le dispositif qui était déployé j'ai eu
peur d'être sérieusement blessé parce
que les grenades elles étaient attirés
précisément elle tombait vraiment au
milieu de tout le monde j'ai vu
une rivière juste devant moi
donc on a d'autres audios qu'on va faire
écouter
ça lui permet de passer d'un TPMP en
même temps vous savez les grenades qui
ont été tirées elles ont été tirées en
nombre si elles sont tirées en nombre
c'est qu'il y avait des hordes de mecs
qui attaquaient moi j'en ai eu les
gendarmes au téléphone donc je peux vous
le dire des mecs qui attaquer
systématiquement et on le voit les
images seront tarlantes puis les
véhicules incendie aussi pour une fois
il y avait des hordes de gens qui
avancés pour aller en découdre avec les
les gendarmes et que faisaient les
gendarmes pour repousser évidemment il
canardent au lance au lance-grenades
c'est systématique et c'est très simple
ça évite d'aller au contact donc ce que
dit le ce fameux reporter est totalement
alors vous allez voir vous allez réagir
sur ce qu'il dit là aussi parce que
façade de telles scènes de chaotibo
hyper pour lui évidemment mais également
pour ses collègues et après je vous
ferai écouter un autre un autre audio
ils sont il y a un coup de gueule contre
la police vous allez lui répondre
un avec le visage en sang un autre était
blessé à la jambe c'était vraiment un
carnage une vraie boucherie je
m'attendais pas à vivre quelque chose
comme ça en France tout ça pour protéger
un trou
et derrière la situation a été très
dramatique il le dit pour il dit pour
les manifestants et pour les forces de
l'ordre mais si on se reporter à la
situation aurait pu être mieux gérer
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
à un Bruno son objectif lui dit qu'il ne
ça lui empêche pas de pousser un petit
coup de gueule sur la gestion de la
situation pour lui ça a été mal géré
vous allez dire ce que vous en pensez
Bruno
les forces de l'ordre sont censées
protéger la population mais au niveau du
maintien de l'ordre je pense que le
boulot n'est pas fait j'ai peur qu'un
jour il y a un drame là
il y a deux personnes qui sont dans le
coma il y a quelqu'un qui a perdu un œil
aussi hein
un chemin aussi à la dernière
manifestation à Paris qui a perdu un œil
oui il a oublié les 50 gendarmes qui
sont gravement blessés et des centaines
de gendarmes aussi qui ont été aussi
moins blessés et les deux fameux dont
ils parlent c'est quand même un qui a
été reconnu comme activiste très connu
dans les manifs pour [__] le bordel
avec les Black Bloc donc effectivement
si malheureusement il est dans le coma
ce soir pas celui-ci l'autre enfin ils
sont deux très gravement blessés mais
c'est son problème il avait qu'à pas
essayer de passer à la souris de monter
à la souder des gendarmes encore une
fois bon il a une vision évidemment qui
est anti Antipolis ça se voit bien les
gendarmes qui sont positionnés dans ces
manifs il faut bien comprendre qu'elles
sont là pour protéger je vois pas
l'intérêt Corée les gendarmes même pour
le gouvernement d'ailleurs mais les
gendarmes qui sont présents de monter à
l'assaut des manifestants c'est pas du
tout leur but ils ont 6000 personnes
devant eux il y a 5000 de gens qui
manifestent simplement normalement et
vous avez mis le connard de vent qui qui
veulent un découdre à tout prix qui
viennent toutes parts
le discernement il y est parce que toute
manière on avait plusieurs rangées de
manifestants et ces mecs là j'avais
raison de l'employer le mot
des manifestants comme on l'a vu avec
les quads c'est pour aller sur des des
groupes muscules sûrement très radicaux
qu'il faut disperser à tout prix ce que
font les bras à Paris lorsqu'il y a des
manifs il y a des mini groupes très bien
compris maintenant il faut les casser
systématiquement et tout de suite alors
on va voir le point de vue de la
gendarmerie on comprend comment autant
de force de l'ordre on peut être blessés
regardez on va voir maintenant le point
de vue de la gendarmerie du vent
et les casseurs et les Black Blocs qui
ont pu s'approcher au plus près des
forces de l'ordre par moment on a vu
même un convoi de gendarmerie attaqué et
incendie regardez
[Musique]
on remonte toutes les images à une des
images les plus impressionnantes de
cette journée de si violence c'est
l'intervention surprise des forces de
l'ordre monter sur des quads
regarder où on les voit comment
notamment disperser les manifestants
nous ont des grenades et des gaz lacrymo
ça c'est vrai que les quads
maintenant pour disperser les groupes
et puis parmi les nombreux blessés il y
a un photographe de presse alors qui
était sur place pour le journal
Sud-Ouest il a été blessé à la tête et
aux mains par des projectiles lancés par
les Black Blocs
nous avons décidé de nous mettre à
l'abri derrière le dispositif de
gendarmerie donc très vite les
manifestants ont progressé avec des g de
cocktail Molotov et de bombes
incendiaires et des pierres dans tous
les sens
en les envoyant très haut ce qui
finalement donc a permis aux projectiles
de passer derrière les camions de
gendarmerie c'est là où on a pris un
cocktail Molotov le côté de la tête je
pense qui a éclaté devant nous et puis
on est on a essayé de courir derrière en
traversant les jets de pierre alors
pendant des heures ce qu'on a entendu
c'est des sons de projectiles lancé par
les Black Blocs l'explosion de cocktail
Molotov ou de grenades lancées par les
forces de l'ordre alors regardez c'est
fou on a du mal à croire que c'était
c'est vraiment des scènes de guerre et
des bruits de scène de guerre écoutez
[Applaudissements]
alors côté manifestants dénonce de
nombreuses violences policières comme ce
journaliste excessif de la force
regardez on a fait une petite compil
aussi comme ça on est vraiment les deux
côtés
[Musique]
alors dernière image c'est une des plus
grosses polémiques qu'on concernant
cette journée c'est le rôle des secours
et de leur intervention sur place les
manifestants blessés étaient pris en
charge un peu dans le désordre par les
médicaments
aussi de ce qui a pu se passer ce
weekend regarder
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est voilà c'est vraiment
des scènes incroyables vraiment on a eu
du mal à y croire